Darrin thanks for joining us any
reaction from sponsors with Tiger Woods
I think there was no reaction I can tell
you there was no reaction at least
publicly ban which to me suggested that
one either they were finding out more
information or two they didn't feel the
need to react at all which would suggest
to me that when Tiger is in some point
of irrelevance now which he kind of is I
mean people are already saying he's
either going to be out on the course and
doing something or if he's not playing
golf then nothing really matters and
some of these sponsors are so new you
know in the last six months he's gotten
three new sponsors which since 2008 and
everything went down he hasn't had that
speed and that's not because he's more
relevant it's because Nike decided to
get out of the equipment business so he
went to Bridgestone four balls and
tailor-made for clubs and he lost the
bag deal because MusclePharm really
couldn't afford him anymore so monster
comes in so he's dealing with these new
sponsors and I feel like they feel like
there's not a connection with him yet so
they might as well not make the
connection now especially they'd off the
course what do you get out of this
association with Tiger I think and I
have not been privy to the actual deals
but I think what you get is a potential
added value if somehow he does what
everyone thinks he can't do which is
somehow come back company comes back and
win something so I think the way these
deals are written is they're heavily
incentive Laden um and you know not too
much guaranteed money up front certainly
not what he was getting with Nike and if
he wins you become part of it and so I
feel like that's where we're at at his
career now where you feel like as a
company if you have a chance to get in
it would be so big if he did win that if
you can create a deal that if he did win
you'd pay more and still that would be
great return and
you're going to do it why is Jordan's
brand so sustainable well some people
would argue it's because he got all of
his career done in the age of not having
social media because that would be
interesting but um you know I I think
that uh he is so strong in what he did
in his career and then you know the
Jordan Brand has become such a
sustainable one and such a such heat to
it you know even just this weekend of
you know a big release and you're
hearing about the releases and releases
are trending on Instagram and Twitter
and social media I mean I I think it's
just by virtue of the fact that there is
a great product associated with it that
sustains what he was able to build when
you know he had a career and there and
there's nothing like it and you know we
said Tiger you know might be the next
Jordan taking over thing I mean there is
no next Jordan in basketball there's
probably no next Jordan everywhere and I
know that's going to disappoint levar
ball but but I think you have to say
that Darren Ravel from the mothership
sports business reporter you segwayed
into levar ball if if your son is going
to be a Los Angeles Laker you have that
LA market does it make sense to be your
own brand or would you see him
is it possible to reach out to these
other bigger shoe sponsors yeah I mean
the whole make sense thing I mean yeah
did did will run leave something on the
table if he were able to create his own
brand I guess but it was strange to me
that when the Lakers did get the number
to pick that Lavar didn't at least fold
some of his cards and go back to the
shoe company is in earnest like so so so
originally the original deals that Nike
Adidas Under Armour were going to offer
Lonzo ball would be five years
ten million dollars two million dollars
a year after the Lakers thing goes down
and you have the opinion that used now
you know the perfect scenario is going
to unfold the New Deal might be five
years twenty million just by virtue of
what happens on whatever may 16th on the
night of water you didn't do anything
but you're now lined up to go too late
but what is Lavar ball do instead of
saying he now wants some billion dollars
he now wants three billion dollars so I
guess the story becomes more intriguing
in that if he goes to the Lakers if you
believe he's going to the Lakers he just
could have made much more money maybe
double his deal on that alone and
decided to pass and I think that's why
this story is something that people want
to read even though they say they aren't
they are clicking at home they are
looking at this he is trending on
Twitter every time he talks Lamar is so
I think it makes the story a whole lot
more intriguing and that he's continuing
to go along with the fact that he
believes this could be a real brand
which will ultimately be up the long
haul at how good he is is Lamar Ball
good at what he's doing right now he's
unbelievable he's unbelievable and again
he makes people so mad the place that
you don't want to be in this world in
the middle but is he you unbelievable in
a grind away completely luck huh is he
unbelievable in a good way I don't know
unbelievable at getting attention he's
not many people love him but a lot of
people hate him and as long as it's not
illegal what you're doing that's okay
people don't want to give him credit for
maybe he this is not all premeditated
but people don't want to give him credit
for what he's done and that is every
time he opens his mouth he's trending
even if it seems stupid people don't
want to give them credit for the fact
that he was not dumb
to create this $500 shoe which is coming
out on November 24
because he has to order the shoes
because he's not going to have it in a
discount store because it's custom
ordered and he could make it a small
order and that's $500 at 495 is
basically the least he could have it
because if only five people ordered
shoes it might be $300 a pair to make so
he's figured that out he's he's he's
smarter than people give him credit for
and he's a better talker
than people give it credit for Darrin
thanks for joining us we appreciate it
you got it that's Darren Ravel from the
mothership the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience